Good afternoon.
This is Patricia Chinoka of women of Zimbabwe.
And this afternoon
we've just handed in a petition
at No. 10 to the Prime Minister,
where we are asking the government to review
the health care workers dependent children's visas.
We believe that the Home Office are systematically
barring the children of the healthcare workers
from joining their parents in the UK. Uh,
the majority,
uh, of those visa refusals are affecting single
black African mothers,
predominantly from Zimbabwe,
Zambia, Kenya,
Ghana, Nigeria,
Uganda and South Africa.
Uh, and, and we really want the government to,
to, to have a look at this
because these healthcare workers
have come to look after
the most needy and vulnerable people within our society.
Uh, and they are feeling in a much needed gap
in their health and social care. Six of us.